After 40 years we're going back to the moon.
Or rather this can of powdered sports drink is.
Not satisfied with cluttering up the planet surface with advertorial eyesores...
...human kind is reaching out to our nearest celestial neighbor.
Japanese beverage maker Otsuka is sending a specially designed cannister of Pocari Sweat...
...to the lunar surface aboard Space X's Falcon 9.
The first planned private moon landing mission set for October of 2015.
Otsuka hopes this stuff will inspire young people to become astronauts...
...who will one day reach the lunar surface, down the can's contents...
...and realize their dreams were  as empty as the calories they just consumed.
Though it will more likely launched a gold rush of marketing into space.
Where no one can hear you scream, "Stop trying to get me to buy your useless products!"
One day if the moon hits your eye like a big pizza pie, it may just be Domino's.